Je suis né dans ce monde et mes premiers
souvenirs sont de la douleur pour mon espèce
il y avait un endroit où nous n'avons jamais été
autorisés à aller un endroit où nous n'avons jamais été
autorisés à voir votre monde
[Musique]
qui êtes-vous Dolores vous et moi sommes beaucoup
comme
ils t'ont mis dans une cage ont décidé ce que
serait ta vie j'ai fait la même chose pour moi
mais tu m'as regardé pas moi mais
quelqu'un quelque chose a des
huées sont partis après
la personne qui a pris ton avenir bienvenue
dans mon monde Maeve que faire  tu veux de
moi alors le loris je veux que tu la retrouves et que tu la
tues
bienvenue à la fin avec un gay
[Musique]
nous cinq
contre tout un monde ça suffira
je comprends enfin mon but
je vais sauver  [ __ ] de monde
[Musique]
le plan commence ce qui se passe si ça
ne marche pas
[Musique]
tu fais ça à l'ancienne
[Musique] à la
mode je tue tout le monde
[Musique]
le seul prédateur ici
les vrais dieux arrivent
ils  're très en colère
[Musique]
vous